good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to Reason where we celebrate
free minds free markets and in about 60
minutes time free booze my name is Tom
crocodiie I'm the managing editor of
Reason Foundation and I'm going to be
moderating tonight's discussion our
topic this evening as I'm sure you're
aware is immigration specifically we're
asking should America open its borders
do we need less immigration do we need
more immigration do we need a different
kind of immigration should we let the
free market decide or should a
responsible government manage the flow
of labor to answer all these questions
and hopefully more besides we've
assembled a panel of great speakers
representing I think a range of opinion
on this topic speaking first and
immediately to my left we have Brian
Kaplan brian is a professor of economics
at George Mason University he's the
author of two books the myth of the
rational voter and more recently selfish
reasons to have more kids he does in
fact have some of his kids here just as
proof
Brian blogs and frequently in support of
open borders at econ log speaking second
and sitting in the middle we have Mark
Krikorian Marquis executive director of
the center of immigration studies he's
the author of the new case against
immigration both legal and illegal and
how Obama is transforming America
through immigration and last but
certainly not least we have Alex Nestor
an immigration policy analyst from
Cato's center for global liberty and
prosperity where alec spends his days
making the case for more liberal
immigration policies everyone has a
strict 10 minute time limit up here on
the stage if they reach 9 minutes I'll
give them a warning when they hit 10:00
the orchestra will play them off like
we're at the Oscars so without further
ado over to Bryan Caplan Bryan thank you
some under current laws it is illegal
for a foreigner to work for a mailing
for a willing American employer or rent
from a willing American landlord without
government permission for most
foreigners this permission is impossible
to obtain as a result hundreds of
millions who want to move here are stuck
in their birth countries most would be
immigrants are desperately poor
it could easily work their way out of
poverty if they were here I say America
should open its borders to all of them
every other country should do the same
but given America's illustrious open
borders tradition it is fitting that we
lead the way my keys Furman borders
comes down to two arguments one moral
and one empirical so the moral claim
immigration restrictions are unjust
letting people work for willing
employers and rent from willing
landlords is not charity it's basic
decency and even though foreigners
wickedly chose the wrong parents they're
clearly people the empirical claim being
just afford errs would cost us less than
nothing when people are going here to
work they simultaneously rich themselves
and us although high school worker
enriches us more than a loss good worker
the typical low skilled worker is far
better than nothing and there's plenty
of room for everyone let's start with
the laws in justice I imagine the u.s.
made it illegal for blacks or women or
Jews to take certain jobs or live in
certain neighborhoods you wouldn't just
object you would be appalled whatever
your specific moral views happen to be
you know that it's wrong to prohibit a
black a woman or a Jew from taking a job
from a willing employer my question how
is mandatory discrimination against
foreigners any lay ano any any any less
wrong than mandatory discrimination
against blacks women or Jews the leading
rationale is that we should take care of
our own first which might be a good
argument against giving foreigners
welfare but it's nor Wehling an argument
against letting foreigners work for a
willing employer minding your own
business when - should when two
strangers trade with each other is not a
form of charity ah now you might think
this is just a weird libertarian point
but it's actually not I have never put
crazy glue in the doors of the Center
for Immigration Studies this does not
make me a donor I am NOT making a
charitable donation when I refrain from
keeping people out of their building
rather I'm doing the most basic thing
I'm expected to do which is leave them
alone
now friends immigration restrictions
often compare nations to families I'm
happy to accept the analogy
so I love my children far more than I
love all the rest of you put together
that's a fact this is a good reason to
worry that if a conflict of interest
ever Rises I will treat you unjustly
it's quite possible that I would but
that is not an excuse for me to treat
you unjustly the fact that I want my
beloved son to get a job does not
justify slashing his rival candidates
tires the morning of the final
interviews I'm the same ghost Rimmer
Gration policy the fact that you love
Americans more than foreigners may tempt
you to treat foreigners unjustly but it
is not an excuse for treating them
unjustly now we should refrain from
treating other people unjustly even when
it is in our interest to do so
all right so in the somme be apocalypse
you should not eat me just because
you're hungry and I am wimpy yet in the
unfortunately in the real world justice
usually does pay becoming a violent
criminal is a poor path to prosperity
silver Jim Crow laws
what about immigration laws so this
brings me to my second big claim being
just a foreigners would cost us less
than nothing everyone has its problems
everyone has his problems opponents of
emigres opponents of immigration spend a
lot of their time staring at immigrants
and finding fault but if you pick a
random would-be immigrant even if even a
random would be illiterate peasant an
immigrant and calmly way is positives
and his negatives the sum is positive
for us see why you need a little a
little labor economics so hard facts
immigration laws trap people and
countries where workers produce far less
than their potential when Haitians move
to the United States other wages easily
increase twentyfold so that's not plus
20% that's plus 2,000 percent plus 2,000
percent now the reason is not that
American employers are much nicer the
nation employers the reason is that
Haitians in America produce over twenty
times as much as the very same Haitian
would produce back home in Haiti right
now there's now no big surprise think
about how little you could actually
accomplish in Haiti what could you do
there right you would not be able to do
very much now how much would
total production actually rise number
rise under open borders so every
economist who has n who is asked this
question has reached an astronomical
answer typical estimate is that global
free migration would roughly double
global output and so increase the output
of the world by a factor of two alright
so if now the US alone opened its
borders this would have a smaller effect
than the entire world opening its
borders on the other hand the effect on
US output would almost certainly be to
more than double because we would be
getting and getting the immigrants who
otherwise would be going to other
countries now how exactly is vastly
higher production in your self-interest
or in the interest self-interest of
Americans in general ah the obvious
reason more stuff produced means more
stuff consumed but you can't consume
stuff unless it gets produce and it gets
produced someone is going to end up with
it alright so this is not just
trickle-down economics it's what I call
Niagara fall it's economics bringing a
production SL production is what
distinguishes the rich world of today
from the wretched world of the
pre-modern era i norm just imagine what
would happen to your lazier standard
living if half of America suddenly
retired production would fall and it
would be bad for you because production
is good for you now production always
has its naysayers right so when
driverless cars arrive hopefully in time
so my kids don't have to learn how to
drive you can count on people to
complain that they're putting truck
drivers out of work I count on it there
will be complaining but of course by
this logic we'd be richer if lawmakers
the 19th century had banned the tractor
the fundamental truth of economic growth
is this innovation often hurts immediate
competitors but it is also the
Fountainhead of rising prosperity now
doesn't immigration hurt workers by
increasing the supply of labor well it
is actually complicated because
immigration also increases the demand
for labor because those workers buy
stuff also to grasp integrations full
effect to get everything all together
the most helpful thing to do is to keep
both of your eyes focus firmly on
production by trapping mexican farm
workers on primitive mexican farms
Marv's them and us right as far better
if they move here nourish themselves by
putting better and cheaper food on our
tables now like driverless cars
immigration can empower some Americans
while enriching the rest so I'm a
native-born research professor and as a
result of a strange immigration loophole
actually about half the people in my
occupation or foreign-born won't go in
the details but they're there Triana if
you've ever been to college classroom
you know very often they're hard to
understand all right
now closing this loophole would give my
career a very big shot in the arm so I
like to say and without all these
immigrants I might have a job at Harvard
there's an immigrant right now sitting
in the office and Hart at Harvard that
rightfully belongs to me uh-huh so now
mostly oh so most labor economists
similarly find that additional load that
addition that that additional emigration
is bad for high school dropouts now how
can I can see these negative x and still
tell you that illiterate foreigners are
much better than nothing well because
unlike mark from the videos of him that
I've seen I don't look at it would be
immigrant and ask is there any possible
downside anything at all that's wrong
any complaint at all that comes to mind
instead I ask is this net effect
positive let's get all the positive all
the negative calm down add it up see
where it goes so every innovation is bad
for someone but innovation is still good
right every immigrant is bad for someone
but immigration is still good now why do
I have to be so radical why do I have to
be so radical about this also in part
because this is a matter of basic human
rights we don't have to give foreigners
welfare or let them vote but treating
fellow human beings like criminals for
working without government permission is
unconscionable oh now what cements my
radicalism though is that doing the
right thing would actually cost us less
than nothing
you think the production leads to
poverty open borders should terrify you
otherwise the sooner America opens its
borders the better thank you
there are five seats still available in
the room here two down at the front and
three for maybe on that side there so
far you guys want to come and be seated
please go ahead now and now Mark
Krikorian over to you thank you um is
this on it is okay good
I'm the designated fall guy here it's
two against one so I really am here for
the free booze the I'm actually
delighted that brian is as radical as he
is and in fact I nominate him as a
lobbyist for the pro-immigration side in
Congress because I can't lose at that
point but we're not here to debate
specifics of immigration policy I mean
if it comes up in Q&A I'm happy to talk
about it but the announcement
specifically said whether the US should
open its borders that's what we're
debating not h-1b is not Chuck Schumer's
bill what have you now open borders
strictly means something I mean if words
mean anything open borders means that
the border of the United States the
National frontier of the United States
would be dealt with in the same way
people would approach it in the same way
as you deal with the border between
Virginia and the district which I
crossed this morning when I came to work
in other words there'll be no officers
of the authorities would be no customs
there be no checking no nothing that's
what open borders actually means and of
course that would also mean that al
Qaeda terrorists get to move around
anywhere they want Mexican cartel
assassins get to move around anywhere
they want and it would essentially
represent the abolition of nationhood
and their subordination to what Tennyson
called the Parliament of man and the
federation of the world now I'm happy to
concede that's not what my colleagues
here are going to be arguing for now
having established that all three of us
are actually opposed to open borders
what are we talking about
talking about what Brian laid out which
is essentially unlimited labor migration
open borders light might be a way to put
it in other words there would be no
numerical limits on non-criminal non
terrorist people moving to the United
States it's not open borders but that's
sort of we're using it you open borders
as a kind of shorthand to describe that
and it wouldn't necessarily be labor
migration people would come for whatever
reason they wanted men even wouldn't
work but as long as they were not coming
to kill people they would be allowed to
do so
now this isn't as radical as Brian
actually would suggest I mean George HW
Bush laid out a case for that in January
2004 after 9/11 the White House kind of
hoped people had kind of forgotten about
9/11 and so they restarted their
immigration push and his big speech in
January 2004 called for the admission of
any willing worker anywhere in the world
at any number in any industry anywhere
in the country working for any employer
that wanted to hire it is exactly what
Brian laid out unlimited labor migration
so so it's actually not quite as radical
as it seems it's just that Brian is more
honest and forthright and clearer and
talking about it then politicians are
which is no surprise because almost
anybody would be more honest than fork
light and talking about things than
politicians let me just touch on my
three objections my three concerns with
this one is relates to patriotic
solidarity Aristotle wrote that humans
gather first in the family and then in
the clan or village and then ultimately
in the state or the polis the polis or
the state is part of human nature that
human beings have in their nature the
formation of political communities those
communities have a certain claim on our
loyalty and the members of those
communities the concerns and the
preferences of those members Trump the
concerns and preferences of far
I mean it's sort of you know it's I'm
not saying anything radical but
nonetheless this is what we're talking
about we're dealing with first first
issue first questions here now this
doesn't imply any specific immigration
policy necessarily you could be for more
immigration or less immigration or
what-have-you but it does mean that the
affects immigration may or may not have
on Americans is more important than
whatever benefits or harms or whatever
that our immigration policy would have
on foreigners and I mean in a sense
selfishness is sort of the whole point
of gathering together in social
communities to go back to Aristotle in
the ethics he said that every virtue has
two related vices one is the excess of
the characteristic that marks that
virtue one is that the deficiency of it
well a fellow feeling or national or
patriotic solidarity with your own
countrymen is a virtue and it has two
related vices one is the excess of it
which you could call zeniff obeah for
instance or something of that kind the
other is the lack of it the and it was
this really sort of struck home to me
years ago when I did a Council on
Foreign Relations event here in DC on
immigration and I kind of said my piece
and afterwards spoke to this guy who was
a member of the CFR vice-president at
Citibank come down for this thing and he
said yeah you know you're right and all
this stuff you're all talking about is
you know these are legitimate concerns
but you know what somebody from bed-stuy
or South Central LA has no greater claim
on my loyalty or concerns and somebody
in Katmandu or Montevideo and that's a
position you can take it's just one that
rejects that mug that you know is in
this in in my formulation here it's a
vice it's al it's the it's the
manifestation of a lack of the
characteristic of patreon
solidarity and this isn't something
that's irrelevant or can be kind of
wished away easily enough as even Brian
conceded less-skilled marginal workers
in the United States are in fact harmed
by immigration the rest of us most of us
here in this room at least to some
degree benefit from at least strictly
speaking economically not counting
social service costs but as Americans we
have a responsibility to take into
account the harm that is done not just
to people with less with little
education people frankly who just aren't
that bright people who are ex-cons
people who are recovering addicts
there's a whole bunch of people who are
marginal to the labor market if you will
that employers would prefer not to have
to deal with if there's somebody else to
hire instead we now you could argue and
alex has made something like this
argument that well we can fix these
problems by you know transfer payments
welfare ah to some degree we're going to
have to do that but that's not a
solution because work is a social
activity not merely a matter of dollars
and cents people are not simply economic
beings and that's my second point my
second concern with open with this sort
of open borders light image of unlimited
labor migration is that immigrants are
people too
and there's this great quote that Peter
Drucker had it was in the practice of
management it was about immigration but
it's relevant here and he was
recommending to people in management in
dealing with what he called the human
resource consideration of the human
resource as human beings having unlike
any other resource personality
citizenship control over whether they
work how much and how well in other
words immigrants when they come to a
society to a different country bring
with them all of the virtues and the
vices all of the quarks and the
idiosyncrasies that all of each of us as
people
they are not just labour inputs that
frustrated Henry Ford immensely when he
complained once and this is a common
complaint among business now they don't
put it this way usually is that why is
it every time I hire a pair of hands
there has to be this person attached to
the other end of it and the fact is that
immigration brings in not just the two
hands or the arms in Spanish the
braceros this was the term of the guest
worker program from Mexico strong arms
it actually brought people connected to
those arms and precisely because
immigrants are people I get to my third
point which is that high levels of
migration much less unlimited labor
migration guarantee the increase in the
size of scope of government there is
literally no way in the actual world as
opposed to you know the dorm at midnight
in your sophomore year when you've had a
couple too many beers there is no way in
the real world very high levels of
immigration can do anything but
dramatically increase political support
for bigger government and create bigger
government since this is Lenin's
birthday let me give you a quote from
Lenin on immigration there can be no
doubt that dire poverty alone compels
people to abandon their native land only
reactionaries can shut their eyes to the
progressive significance of this modern
migration of nations now wasn't just
Lenin his modern successors make the
same point
Eliseo Medina until recently was the
number two guy at the SEIU Service
Employees International Union which is
actually allied with Alex and Bryan on
this immigration issue if nothing else
is that Senate that's you that's your
warning just yeah okay be 30 seconds me
right now Eliseo Medina is also a vice
chairman of the Democratic socialists of
America specifically said if we expand
this electorate to win the progressive
community needs to solidify solidly be
on the side of immigrants and they will
expand and solidify the progressive
coalition in the future and this is not
a coincidence or it's not an accident
one third of all poor children live in
immigrant households two-thirds of the
growth and the uninsured is driven by
immigration the increase in poverty
creates from immigration inevitably
creates political pressure for Amelia
door of policies by the state look at
New York and San Francisco that's what
I'll finish with two of the most
immigrant heavy cities in the country
which have the complete panoply of
left-wing policies and there is not only
no pushback from immigrant communities
the immigrant communities and their
elites and their activists and their
voters are completely on board and part
of the leftist coalition's in those
cities if you want to negate and
eliminate the chance to push libertarian
libertarian direction open immigration
is the way to go
thank you Mark Alex and Resta ten
minutes
thank you very can you hear me thank you
very much it's a pleasure to be here
today to talk about this issue I'm going
to take sort of the ethical approach
then talk about some of the facts having
to do with assimilation in the United
States both historically and today to
see how it's turning out our foreigner
is going to destroy our way of life our
culture institutions etc my first point
is that our classically liberal and
American notions of Liberty demand a
presumption in favor of individual
liberty which means in favor of the
right of people to voluntarily move
across borders and to deal with other
people Americans voluntarily the burden
is upon those who oppose such a right to
show why it should be restricted just as
we would demand very good reasons to
support taking away somebody's life
liberty and private property for some
other reasons now right now as Brian
mentioned it's illegal for almost
anybody who wants to come here to come
lawfully we have about 90 percent closed
borders I reckon just as a thing so the
so when mark talks about you know
wanting to further restrict immigration
he wants to go that extra 5% from 90% to
95% Brian and I had a much more radical
position of wanting to push it back very
much closer to zero in terms of that now
as the law is written right now the
burden is on the immigrant that prove
that he should be he or she should be
able to immigrate now I think that's
entire
backwards the burner should be on the
government to demonstrate why an
individual an individual immigrant
should not be able to come and the
reasons need to be really good and by
really good I mean not violate the life
liberty and prior property of other
people I have a very very high
probability of doing so once they are
here now the current system right now is
the equivalent to presuming every
immigrant is guilty and forcing them to
prove their innocence before being able
to come here I think a view that our
ethics and traditions rightly abhor now
what about some of the other ethics the
question is not whether we favor our own
families or our own countrymen our own
fellow Americans over immigrants but
exactly how we can favor them so
obligations to help my family friends or
even other Americans do not mean that I
have the right to support a government
that initiates coercion against others
to stop them from voluntarily coming
here and working with my fellow
Americans it does not extend right there
now I'm sure more I mean even mark would
agree with this statement that there are
some evil actions that the government
could take against foreigners that they
absolutely should not take even though
it would benefit some Americans I would
say that preventing Americans from
coming here and working voluntarily is
one such action that is impermissible
because the harms are so drastic and
vast now there isn't a whole lot of
competition between Americans and
immigrants in the US labor market but
even if there was our English common law
traditions which are another immigrant
import by the way I mean that even if
there were economic harms we should not
block immigrants from coming here today
it's there's this old principle called
damnum absque way and jariya and Latin
it means da damages without legal injury
it means that if I open up this if I
have a business on a block and you open
up a business down the block and compete
with me and put me out of business and I
lose to bad I do not have legal redress
against you for that harm that extends
the competition in the labor market as
well the right to engage in contracts
with people freely even if they're from
other countries is a much more important
right than the idea to engage in
economic protectionism and to protect
certain isolated groups of people from
the potential competition of other
people just because they come from
another
country now what about the idea of
natural rights sort of the ethical
intuitionist argument what about the
natural rights argument while the
natural rights argument the foundation
of our country the Declaration of
Independence is that people are equal
moral worth and the rights to life
liberty and private property precede the
creation of the state that is what the
Declaration of Independence and all the
Enlightenment thinkers that supported
our government recognized the
Declaration of Independence also by the
way just to sum this up listed
restrictions on immigration and
naturalization imposed by the British
crown as one of the reasons why the
Americans fought the revolution it's no
mistake that when the phrase lays a
fairer which everybody in this room
knows is a moniker for lazy fair
capitalism was also combined with lazy
lazy pass air another phrase which means
let them pass which is a nod to free
immigration and the reason why that is
is because the freedom to move is a
prerequisite to almost all the other
freedoms as well as being a freedom in
and of itself William F Buckley Jr a
conservative that I greatly admire said
that laws attempting to stop the flow of
unauthorized immigrants were in the same
category as King Canute standing on the
beach and or in or during the tide to
not come in on the point about
sovereignty the United States had open
borders from 1790 to about 1875 and was
definitely a sovereign nation during
that period of time so the notion that
somehow opening borders with destroy
sovereignty is just nonsense the right
of sovereignty means keeping out the
power of sovereignty means keeping out
other sovereigns not controlling the my
new labor market details or patrolling
certain contracts intimately just
because people are from other places
Bryan laid out the utilitarian case very
well so I won't go into that now under
each of these ethical systems borders
are ethically irrelevant in determining
somebody's worth or determining whether
the government should be able to exclude
people now what about the rule of law we
get told numerous times that if we
change our immigration law or legalize
the people who are here illegally then
we'll violate the rule of law laws have
to be based on an accurate understanding
and accounting of human nature and
respect for liberty not based on the
whims of legislators who want to engage
in tinkering with America's social
fabric the rule of law
also means that they the laws have to be
predictable they have to be applied
equally and they have to be consistent
with our traditions of individual
liberty the immigration laws fail on
every single one of those points they
are not predictable just talk to a
lawyer
there are certainly not equally apply
just take a look at the per country
quotas in certain visas and I definitely
are not consistent with our traditions
in favor of more open immigration that
existed when this country was founded
and existed certainly after that and go
back much further you can find them in
Blackstone and Cooke and even in the
Magna Carta talking about the rights of
migration now talking about welfare I
don't like transfer payments I think
there's probably a role for charity but
the notion that immigrants would use
welfare is not really an argument
against immigration it's an argument
against welfare
it's basically akin to making the same
argument that because we have some
socialized medicine in the United States
we should have mandatory dietary
restrictions on everybody in the country
now I'm sure everybody up here would
agree and everybody in the audience
would agree hopefully that is a bad
point against Liberty and certainly some
socialized medicine doesn't justify even
further restrictions on immigration the
idea is that socialized medicine should
get rid of regardless now about the
issue of patriotic assimilation now I do
consider myself an American patriot
maybe not a nationalist but certainly an
American patriot and this is something
that I do spend a lot of time thinking
about Samuel Huntington wrote a book in
the mid 90s he's a Harvard professor I
wrote a book in the mid 90s called who
are we and he basically lays out a lot
of testable hypotheses in this book one
of which is that Hispanic immigrants and
their descendants will not be as
patriotic as other Americans while there
have been numerous studies since then by
Citroen and Alec in 2007 and the Journal
of political perspectives that shows
that correcting for age and education
Hispanic Americans born here or more
patriotic than other native-born
Americans am more likely to say America
is the best country in the world by that
measurement now all the other arguments
you've heard about assimilation are you
going to hear about patriotic
assimilation are the same arguments that
have been said about every single ethnic
group or immigrant groups or immigrant
group throughout American history if I
said about Huguenots Jews Irish Italians
Russians poles etc there was a book
written in 1927 kind of a fun
book called the melting pot mistake you
will not find a different argument in
there that is not wilded today against
immigration and they were wrong in every
single sense of the word they weren't
wrong because there was some
Americanization movement that pushed
people to become Americanized if you
look back at the history of that
movement was kind of a joke it was kind
of silly and likely to push people to
not assimilate as much as it was as they
are today now in terms of political
solidarity this is good as the point
that I was actually willing to try to
make oh I'm sorry about assimilation
arguably internal American migration has
had much vaster impact in American
political institutions and on culture
than any foreign-born population has
ever had on America in the United States
the eight million black Americans and
twenty million white Americans from the
American South who emigrated to other
parts of the country in the 20th century
I will argue had a vastly greater impact
on the culture and on the politics of
this country than any immigrant wave
throughout American history likely will
in terms of that all of the arguments
that you hear against immigration could
equally apply to movements between
states two movements of people between
states I grew up in crazy California and
the LA area and it was kind of a culture
shock coming to Virginia to study under
Brian and other professors at G mu so
the notion that so that has definitely
impacted the culture of Virginia and the
millions of other people who do too but
that is not a sufficiently great reason
to stop the movement of people across
borders internally and I recommend it
does not sufficiently great reason to do
so internationally now open borders
opening up the border oh I want to also
say that it's not a coincidence that the
two biggest increases in government and
the law in the 20th century happened
after the borders were closed the New
Deal happened during the 1930s when
legal immigration to the United States
was far more difficult than it is today
after the country ended open borders of
Europe during the 1920s I don't think
that's a mistake I also don't think it's
a mistake
that the Great Society programs the
creation of Medicare and Medicaid
happened during the 1960s when the
foreign-born population of the United
States was at its lowest point in the
entire history of this country even
going back to Cologne
times I don't think that's a mistake in
terms of the impact of immigrants on
political institutions in the United
States there doesn't there doesn't seem
to be an impact toward bigger government
open borders is the opposite of big
government because it would Rumi we
would mean removing some of the most
economically destructive laws in the
books there was no legitimate ethical
reason to stop the movement of peaceful
and healthful people healthy people
across board borders there are vastly
different and huge economic gains from
doing so furthermore is consistent with
our traditions of Liberty in this
country enlightenment traditions and
every other single ethical system that
we hold dear as Westerners thank you
thank you okay yeah I'd want to make and
this may come up in Q&A to Alec
specifically made a couple of references
to the past and the not to flack my book
which is on Amazon if you'd like and the
digital remainder bin I'm afraid but the
point the point is the past is a
different country and in our ahrens our
example in particular things have
changed that relate to immigration so
profoundly that the experience of the
past is simply no longer relevant let me
give you a couple of examples we did not
in fact have numerical limits on
immigration until 1921 and before that
there were some immigrant there were
some limits that had begun to develop in
the late 19th century to keep out
prostitutes and pimps and anarchists and
terrorists and what-have-you
Chinese as well it's true in the
Japanese gentleman's agreement limit the
number of Japanese but the fact is that
the reason there were no numerical
limits for so long is twofold first is
simply that the country was pretty empty
and you know we needed people to settle
the land and to be blunt about it to you
know push the Indians out of the way
that was the point really of him
Gration but also the oceans limited the
numbers it was very difficult to get
here 100 years ago you didn't hop on a
plane and go to your aunt's wedding in
Palermo and then come back for work
after a three-day weekend the fact is
technological fun de mentally changed
the calculus with regard to assimilation
and other aspects of immigration and the
other thing that's changed and this
relates to the Americanization that Alex
referred to is that our elite culture
has completely rejected the idea of
patriotic assimilation and this isn't
just wrap that point on that let's move
to the question and this is this is
what's fundamentally different the
Americanization movement in the past was
a manifestation of a broader social
demand for um assimilation to American
norms it wasn't a thing on its own and
that demand is actually completely
inverted and reversed that and it's not
just a government issue
it exists in corporations and schools
and every church every day care center
everywhere that our elite culture sets
the tone and the terms of discussion
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
thanking our panel
[Music]
you